from one psychonic child star to
European beauty queens 2023 has seen the
last of many great TV film and video
game actors Lance Kerwin spent his
childhood racking up guest roles as
Plucky kids on 70s Fair like police
story Canon and multiple after school
specials as he grew his starred as
relatable and sensitive team James
Hunter on the drama James at 15 renamed
James at 16 in 1978 playing a realistic
teenager made Kerwin into real-life Teen
Idol in the late 1970s and early 1980s
he parlayed this status into Parts in
the TV movie the boy who drank too much
and the hit miniseries adaptation of
Stephen King's Salem's Lot in which he
played lead vampire resistor Mark Petry
it wasn't a dream
Kerwin bounced around TV for years
before largely retiring from acting
after an appearance in 1995's outbreak
according to his daughter Kerwin died on
January 24 2023 in San Clemente
California he was 62. early Bowen was a
consummate character actor highly
recognizable by his face voice and
demeanor for any number of the nearly
300 projects He was involved with from
the mid-1970s to the 2010s it was
probably best known for his recurring
role across two decades worth of
Terminator movies and the first three
entries of the Sci-Fi franchise Bowen
played persistent criminal psychologist
Dr Peter Silberman Bowen also co-starred
an Alien Nation nine to five and my
stepmother is an alien on the small
screen Bowen enjoyed recurring roles on
Mama's Family scarecrow and Mrs King and
Webster he also had an illustrious
career as a voice actor contributing to
animated projects like Kim Possible the
new Batman adventures Pinky and the
Brain and Clifford the Big Red Dog on
January 6 2023 TMZ reported that the
character actor had died the previous
day in Hawaii a family friend told
variety that Bowen had recently been
diagnosed with lung cancer he was 81. an
art student and beauty queen screen
Legend Gina Lola Brigida moved into
acting in her native Italy just after
World War II this was an explosively
creative era for Italian Cinema and Lola
brigidaire was a key part of it she
became a superstar in Europe and an
international sex symbol in the 1950s
headlining a run of Hollywood Hits
including the Hunchback of Notre Dame
Beat the Devil and Solomon and sheba she
ultimately headed back to Italy where
she starred in wrote and directed a
number of films Lola brigidaire didn't
act much after 1973 though she did pop
up on Falcon Crest and The Love Boat she
filled her time by becoming a celebrated
photojournalist and the politician in
2022 she ran for a seat in the Italian
Senate according to NPR Lola Brigida had
leg surgery after she broke a 5 bone in
a fall in September 2022 she died in
Rome on January 16 2023 at the age of
95. Annie worshing was a prolific actor
booking roles on dozens of TV shows
throughout the 2000s along with work in
the original The Last of Us video game I
know where he's at
like who you do
old Warehouse in area five
washing earned particular Acclaim for a
performance says as Julia Brasher on
Bosch the Borg Queen on Star Trek Picard
and Emma Whitmore untimeless she further
distinguished herself by appearing in a
number of fiercely beloved Sci-Fi Action
and fantasy television series her first
ever credit comes from an episode of
Star Trek Enterprise and she later
popped up on series like Angel charms
Supernatural and Revolution viewers
might also remember were Shing from The
Vampire Diaries on which she played
Wicked vampire family matriarch Lily or
24 which saw her portray FBI agent Renee
Walker where Xing also portrayed
duplicitous cult leader Leslie Dean on
the Marvel series runaways according to
deadline doctors diagnosed worshiping
with cancer in 2020 she died on January
29 2023 at the age of 45. in 1977 Adam
Rich began a four-year run as Nicholas
the youngest of the eight Bradford
children on Eight Is Enough Rich went on
to enjoy a number of guest roles on a
variety of Series in including Silver
Spoons Saint elsewhere The Love Boat and
the Six Million Dollar Man tabletop
role-playing game fans might also
remember him from the 1980s dungeon and
Dragons Animated Series in which he
voiced the magical Presto in the 1990s
celebrated author and publisher Dave
Eggers recruited Rich for a massive
prank Edgar's magazine might reported
Rich's death a fictitious Memorial
tribute was so convincing genuine news
outlets attempted to jump on the story
Rich died on January 7 2023 he was 54.
Lisa Loring cemented her Legacy at a
very early age when she portrayed the
iconic and then drawing character of
Wednesday Adams Lauren was the first
actor to ever play the somber girl on
screen making her Mark in 1964's The
Adams Family this performance is still
making waves with her frenetic dance
with co-star Ted custody becoming a meme
in recent years a breakout child star
Loring acted only occasionally after The
Adams Family ended with appearances on
the girl from Uncle Fantasy Island
Barnaby Jones and the long stint on As
the World Turns in the early 1980s her
final work came in the 2015 indie horror
movie dog to spine loring's friend
Laurie Jacobson reported on Facebook
that on January 25th 2023 the actor
suffered a severe stroke she died on
January 28th at the age of 64. Cindy
Williams was an icon of 1970s
entertainment following some do paying
with commercials and guest starring
roles Williams landed big Parts in major
movies by two of the era's most
important filmmakers she played Laurie
and George Lucas's nostalgic Blockbuster
American Graffiti and Anne in Francis
Ford Coppola as a conversation a 1975
performance on Happy Days led to
William's most famous role Shirley
Feeney Shirley and her friend Laverne
serve as intimidatingly older dates for
the show's teenage characters their
episode proved so popular that a Laverne
and Shirley spin-off hit the air in 1976
by the
1977-1978 season it was the most watched
program on television
February 25th 2023 following a brief
illness she was 75. Melinda Dillon
kicked off her acting career in a big
Way by earning a Tony Award nomination
for her performance in the original 1963
production of Edward Albee's who's
Afraid of Virginia Wharf in the 70s she
led the cast of three Classics of the
era how Ashby's Woody Guthrie biopic
Bound for Glory hockey comedy Slap Shot
and Steven Spielberg's sci-fi smash
Close Encounters of the Third Kind
however it wasn't until the 1980s that
Dylan landed her most iconic and
enduring role every year millions of
people watch her play The Parker
family's doting mother in perennial
holiday favorite A Christmas Story Dylan
followed that era spunning hit with
supporting turns and well-received
movies like Harry and the Hendersons
Prince of Tides and Magnolia twice
nominated for Academy Awards both for
Close Encounters of the Third Kind and
absence of malice Dylan was a giant of
20th century film she died on January
9th 2023 at the age of 83. Charles
Kimbrough brought an air of dignified
authority to most of the roles he played
across five Decades of acting he is
perhaps most famous for portraying Jim
Dial on Murphy Brown an upright and
uptight veteran anchor a role that
brought Kim Rowan Emmy Award nomination
in 1990. in recent decades Kimbrough
introduced his deep and serious voice to
the world of cartoons portraying
characters like Victor in Disney's The
Hunchback of Notre Dame and its
spin-offs more to Chalk in recess and Dr
Ficus on dinosaurs kimbrough's voice
also helped make him a star earlier in
his career he was a two-time Tony Award
nominee for his work in big theatrical
Productions on Broadway among many
notable performances Kimbrough
co-starred and Company Candide and my
fair lady Kimbrough also came out of
retirement to reprise the role of Jim
Dial on the 2018 Murphy Brown reboot
Kimbrough died on January 11 2023 in
Culver City California he was 86. Raquel
Welch was among the most iconic and
glamorous movie stars of the 20th
century she made a big move into acting
in 1966 with the sci-fi classic
Fantastic Voyage in which he played a
scientist who has shrunken down and sent
into a sick man's body to investigate
his illness that same year Welch starred
in the prehistoric Adventure 1 Million
Years BC which saw her done a fur bikini
images of her in this unique garment
became the Cornerstone of the film's
marketing Blitz and the legendary pinup
many vampy and showy roles followed in
the 1960s and 1970s with bedazzled The
Three Musketeers and Myra Breckenridge
her most notable recent role that came
in Legally Blonde in which she played
the Widow of a wealthy man whose murder
is one of the central points of the film
according to a statement provided by her
manager the actor died on February 15
2023 following a short period of illness
Welch was 82. in the 1970s and 1980s
Richard Belzer established himself as a
dark acerbic and deeply cynical
wisecracker that's outsider's stance
which saw him deliver an apologetic
social commentary informed many of
Belzer's hosting gigs and acting roles
particularly detective John Munch Belzer
originated the carotron homicide life on
the street and went on to portray him on
Law and Order and Law and Order Special
Victims Unit until 2016. he also brought
the world weary droll-witted and
curmudgingly investigator to the wire 30
Rock Arrested Development and Sesame
Street Bells run Munch shared a cultural
background a complicated attitude about
City Life and an interesting conspiracy
theories by bringing him to such vivid
life the actor became a touchstone to
generations of TV Watchers Elsa died on
February 19 2023 at his home in France
he was 78. you might not recognize Rico
Browning by name but you definitely know
his work in a trio of films in the 1950s
he portrayed the iconic Gillman aka the
creature in Universal's Creature from
the Black Lagoon revenge of the creature
and the creature walks Among Us highly
proficient and the swords after skill
set of stunt performance and underwater
cinematography Browning pulled off
expressive and entirely silent acting
while completely submerged he played the
creature in the movies many underwater
scenes some of which are seriously
lengthy Browning continued to carve out
the nation Hollywood as a Creator and
facilitator of waterlogged projects
directing the underwater scenes in
Caddyshack and Never Say Never Again as
well as co-creating the friendly dolphin
TV series flipper Browning was part of a
very small Club of actors who portrayed
the titular monsters in Universal's
beloved slew of mid-century horror films
in fact he was the last surviving
original performer of the universal
monsters as they're typically known the
actor and filmmaker died on February 27
2023 at home in Florida he was 93. Lance
Reddick brought star power and
irresistible energy to a series of
high-profile and cult projects over the
years his intensity and deep character
work often made them Unforgettable
Reddick broke out on the HBO prison
drama ass but he played undercover
narcotics officer Johnny basil he then
appeared on the celebrated drama the
wire as police Lieutenant Cedric Daniels
Reddick once again played a complex
authority figure on Fringe federal agent
Philip Broyles head of the titular
paranormal office many more TV roles
followed for Reddick including deputy
chief Irving on Bosch Albert Wesker on
Netflix's Resident Evil spin-off series
and deeply evil boss Christian Deville
on comedy Central's corporate how good
to see you again so soon Mr Wick
shall I announce you
film fans know him best to Sharon the
country urge to and sidekick of the John
Wick movies while Gamers will remember
him for years to come as Commander
Zavala of the Destiny video game series
Reddick was discovered dead of natural
causes in his home outside Los Angeles
on the morning of March 17
2023. he was 60 years old the 90s
produced plenty of thoughtful action
movies and Innovative Indies about the
CD aspects of American life and Tom
Sizemore was often a major part of that
movement after his breakthrough role as
a Vietnam War era soldier on the TV
drama China Beach earned him widespread
attention Sizemore appeared as a DEA
agent in Point Break a counter-terrorism
expert in passenger 57 a detective in
True Romance Natural Born Killers and
The Relic and a sergeant in Saving
Private Ryan his career ultimately came
to Encompass more than 200 roles
Sizemore collapsed at his home in Los
Angeles on February 19 2023. it was soon
determined it suffered a brain aneurysm
he died on March 3rd at the age of 61.
foreign